[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mahmoudi un jour à qu'on leur colle aux
huit ans je ne viens quand nous sommes
heureux tout en chantant pour femmes
fils même si je leur chante nicolas
comme avec la joie dominait dans
l'argent
même si on va prendre lyon comme dans
new mai dernier ce en échange de
quelques aux cadeaux madame on attend il
fait veilleux feu même si je me saoule
ali de la province pour mieux parler de
virilité à des mémères décoré comme des
arbres de noël
[Musique]
je sais que dans ma soûlographie chaque
nuit pour des éléphants roses
je me sens très mal chose morose tel du
temps je m'appelais chaque qui est
ruinart à 8 heures seulement
21h01
quelquefois d'êtres humains bien qu'une
heure durant vos beaux beau et qu'on a
la forme même si un jour à macao
je viens gouverneur de tarifs au sérieux
les deux femmes landes
même s'il a cédé trop chaudes heures
j'y sois devenu maître chanteur que ce
soit les proches
même si on m'appelle me concerne je vous
n'en avez pas tous sauvés sommes tous
visés 10 de clermont ferrand de reprise
et de fausses billets
choix
que j'ai une grande cage chaque doha et
on va dans chaque pays et que chaque
pays soit à moi je sais comme que chaque
nuit tout seul au fond de machinerie
pour un public de vieux chinois
je veux chanter ma chanson un mois celle
du temps je m'appelais
qui est tu rigoles l'heure seulement oui
ou être une heure une heure
cette fois et au final cake qu'une heure
durant vos bobos beau et con à la faute
même si un jour au paradis je revienne
comme j'en serais surpris chandhok pour
femme a elle même si je meurs chandelle
et doumbia en regrettant le temps d'en
bas c'est pas tous les jours
[Musique]
l'annuaire mathieu le fils de dieu vous
garde
même si j'avais su c'est là bas
[Musique]
même si toujours trop bonnes pommes
jeune craig le coeur pur esprit à
vouloir consoler les angles je sais
quand même que chaque nuit
j'entendais dans paradis des anges les
seuls et lucifer me chanter ma chanson
la guerre celle du temps je m'appelais
chaque trimestre une oeuvre in un tel
froid est originaire rien qu'une heure
durant mots au bout et qu'on a la soie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]